bonsoir madame david bonsoir je vous ai
senti très ému aujourd'hui c'était
important pour vous qu'on ait cet
hommage à ces femmes de polytechnique et
un hommage de toutes les parlementaires
louis nationale écoutez ça fait 25 ans
bientôt je trouvais que cette année il
fallait marquer le coup et faire quelque
chose d'exceptionnel à l'assemblée
nationale donc j'ai juste lancé l'idée
beaucoup d'autres l'ont reprise maryse
gaudreault carole poirier plein de
femmes des autres partis politiques
et c'était d'avoir un seul texte pour
une fois on allait parler d'un seul
coeur un texte qui serait lu par toutes
les femmes parlementaires ça donc été
fait suivi d'une minute de silence et je
dois le dire aussi il ya eu un
engagement solennel du premier ministre
du québec à l'effet de conserver les
données du registre des armes à feu et
d'avoir ici au québec quoi qu'il arrive
un registre des armes à feu donc là
aussi causer titre alignera en
remerciant le premier ministre oui je
l'était vous m'avez vu plus souvent
qu'autrement cet automne critiquer les
actions du premier ministre et de son
gouvernement
ça me faisait plaisir aujourd'hui
c'était très très sincères de lui dire
merci monsieur le premier ministre vous
donner aux femmes du québec aujourd'hui
vous donner aux hommes aussi aux enfants
toutes les personnes qui un jour ou
l'autre peuvent voir surgir une arme à
feu devant eux vous leur donner de
l'espoir vous donner de l'espoir aux
familles des victimes
donc quelque part là une belle journée
il ya un engagement solennel qui est
très important vous avez souligné que le
drame de polytechnique s'est produit
dans un contexte de misogynie c'est le
terme que vous avez employé 25 ans plus
tard ou est-ce qu'on en est parce qu
après tous ces événements qu'on a vécu
depuis quelque temps au québec en
ontario avec la sphère géante ghomeshi
mais j'ai fait le lien d'ailleurs mais
il ya quelque chose d'intéressant il ya
25 ans la misogynie n'était pas général
mais oui avait une fraction de la
société québécoise une certaine partie
des sommes qu'ils n'acceptaient pas
toutes ces avancées féministes que nous
avions fait aujourd'hui qu'est ce qu'on
découvre en 2014 plein de femmes encore
sont victimes d'actes essayons de
violences à caractère sexuel des hommes
aussi en sont victimes mais au contraire
de 1989 là toute la société québécoise
dit non non on ne veut pas accepter ça
on va devoir agir et je vous souligne
que encore une fois ensemble des femmes
parlementaires ont travaillé très fort
cet hiver on va entreprendre une
commission parlementaire sur cette
question des agressions à caractère
sexuel ça sera suivie d'un forum public
retour en commission recommandations
plein d'action donc vous voyez on
absolument oui très bien madame david
merci beaucoup nous avoir parlé ce soir
merci merci à vous